[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right right before this i was gonna
share some sick news but the minute i
got into the car i got distracted by
mama's fresh-ass outfit
i don't even know what color that is is
that a coach's jacket or a varsity
jacket it's like a lilac like lilac like
a violet let me see get around the
corner what
that is insane can you open the door
please
that
is a freaking fresh
outfit
i'm serious what what i like the
oversized fit
oh and the cream shoes
ninja turtles and some vans like papa
that's freaking cool
that's amazing
all right so the good news that i was
going to share is you guys know that
i've been looking for a dad
dad from my house i'm looking for a
house for my dad and the market's insane
and one of the communities i thought
would be perfect for my pop-pop
there's a three to four hundred person
waiting list and to make it fair they
have a lottery system so it's not first
come first serve and i know it sounds
counterintuitive because the reason why
the lottery system works better is
there's a lot of people that just put
their names on the waiting list by the
time it gets to their name they don't
even want it they're just trying to sign
up for the investment and maybe even
sell like almost like scalping tickets
at like a dodger game or something you
know so they have a lottery system and
i've already been in two lotteries where
you you go online there's three 400
people on the internet on zoom and then
they're just pulling like 10 names and
we haven't gotten it and randomly
the community that we want and the exact
floor plan that my dad wants because
he's by himself he wants something small
came available and it was only because
my agent was there shopping for one of
her other clients and they're like hey i
know your client wants this but this
came up and then she was like wait a
second i have a client that wants this
exactly so we have to go there right now
secure it put down a deposit take it off
the market or else it's going to be
devoured by the other three to 400
people so what i thought was going to be
like over a year of search process
i think we're going to be able to get my
dad a house today
all right so good news
the house is my dad's which is really
really cool um it takes eight months to
build this isn't the floor plan that my
dad's gonna get but i wanna show you
what generally what it looks like so it
looks like this
really cute little
single story house
might actually be a little bit too big
for what my dad needs but in this crazy
market like waiting for the perfect
house is
pretty nuts like we've see my dad wanted
a two bedroom
um
and those come up they'll get snatched
after outbid you know so like we have to
be flexible two or three is cool three
is a little bit bigger because it is
more to clean but also it gives extra
space for tiger to come over have a play
room and
you know like i think family is going to
be over especially once more family
comes over my dad will have relatives
i don't think my mom and my dad are ever
going to get back together because of
divorce but you just never know they
might wanna you know get busy and then
pretend like they're not getting busy my
mom sees another room i don't know but
just more rooms is good to have options
you know but this is pretty much what it
looks like
and i'm so happy
because it's going to be a brand new
house
not sure if my dad has ever experienced
a brand new house before but he is in
his early 70s now and it makes me feel
good that i'm able to help provide that
for him where he can you know move into
a house and be like oh man it's a brand
new house super comfortable and have a
good time living in a brand new state
so the model home we were just in is uh
not a floor plan
but i just wanted to give you guys a
look of what it feels like this is the
exact floor plan that my dad will be
getting it's not the exact house
because they still have to build it they
just pretty much designated what the
lot's gonna be but at least we can walk
through it to see
how it feels like so there's the
entrance you walk in
and i believe they call this the great
room which is like the main living space
and then you can see that's the counter
and i believe you go through here and
it's the master because i saw the floor
plan online and as soon as you walk in
they make it convenient where the master
bedroom was a good size
where the master bedroom you get to come
in and it's close to the great room so
it's convenient
that's probably the closet
that looks like the master bedroom a
bathroom because it has all the
piping
yep
and then you have a
oh maybe this is a walk-in closet
or maybe there's two closets
maybe it's his in her there might be two
closets on
yeah
that is nice
yeah
so let me walk through the walls which
because i can right now
so you come in through here and this
will be my dad's main living area which
is really cool
because he'll just come in and he'll
occupy this space and then the two guest
bedrooms are over here so you walk in
you got
one over here
it's a little bit further away
and then you got another one
over here
a little hallway
and this one oh this one's gonna be nice
this one faces the street with a nice
little window
oh this is so cute this is perfect for
my pops
and i'm assuming this is
laundry yep laundry room
because you got all the plumbing
go through the garage
also actually this is the proper way my
dad would probably come in through
on the modern day like with homes that
have the attached garages like that's
the more norm so my dad will come in
park his car
walk through the through here which is
perfect got dirty clothes throw it
immediately in the laundry and then go
straight here
and
put his groceries here
in the fridge
watch some tv relax
and then go straight to his bedroom
that's awesome
feels great correction my agent just
corrected me she's like you're so dumb
i'm like i know so this is probably the
guest bathroom that's what the plumbing
looks like and this
looks like
the
the laundry room
and that's probably the heat vent right
for the for the dryer
or the gas yep see i don't know [ __ ] but
it goes all up in there
look how cute this community is you have
a nice old view too
so that's like where the houses are
right with the beautiful sky oh shoot
the car here and then
you got the view of the mountains over
there
that's beautiful
that's awesome
feels nice here
i could picture my dad taking his daily
walks
i think my dad really liked this
community now this is a
rare sight we almost never
come to the strip yoda where's baby yoda
inside her jacket
huh you silly goose
now that you've lived here for so long
when you come to the strip does it still
feel like that same like uh novel
feeling coming from l.a i'm never out
here oh novel no it's not novel really
it's i still get that feeling that same
like well i'm in vegas this is crazy
well that whoa yeah but it's not woe
because it's like i'm in vegas
it's more like whoa
this is my house like this is my city
now yeah that's the weird part not like
not that feeling of like oh i'm in vegas
now whoa you know oh yeah yeah that's
true
yeah but yeah we're coming out here to
eat because there's a really yummy place
that um i bought a lunch for mama at one
time
it's called italy
and it has all kinds of italian food
pizza sandwiches ice cream
really good italian coffee and all that
stuff so i'm excited to try it this
place again
um not trying to what am i just saying
i'm gonna get because we all wanted
different things and tucker really
wanted pizza so i was excited i'm not
trying it again because there's
different restaurants i get what you're
saying like you've been here before now
you're glad to be back you're going to
try different things and now i'm going
to try it for the first time wants pizza
so we're all going to get our
fulfillment yes
got it okay we got to drive cut it
we have arrived to italy
it's in there
i'm assuming
and look at how cute these kids look
i think tech is a little bit cold
so we we're trying to get inside
yeah that's real quick and and hold up
like this
oh yeah look at that hair
okay let's go check his favorite your
favorite come on
you ready
oh my
got espresso gelato over here super cool
super cool whoa
look at all that
where do you want to go
the la pasta let's go to the pasta that
way
look at all these snacks
all straight
imported yeah the island from italy
wow
yummy
oh i love this layout it's so pretty
so this is where i got mama bear food
last time i'm in the center of it all
and there's all kinds of food you can
get so they have like a butcher over
there
over here you got italian jellyfish
la
cheese monger and kitchen and since
taiko really wants some pizza we found a
little pizzeria over there
it's called the roman handcrafted
pizzeria
moppers in line
right there
we originally went to the other
restaurant so the other one was more of
like a sit down
but then it was gonna be an hour away
we're really hungry
so we uh didn't get a chance to do it oh
if you guys like uh roast beef
sandwiches this place is so freaking
bomb this one right here
i got here uh prime rib black angus one
last time
so good look at all the stuff they have
roast beef
chicken all of that that was the
restaurant i tried to go to
pizza pasta
for sit down but then it was an hour
wait but as you can see there's lots of
cool food in here
all aspects and all regions of italy
from seafood to meat to sandwiches to
deli meats all of that dessert it's like
forever in vegas make sure come check it
out it's called italy
oh look at all the pizza oh man
oh man
yeah
okay so while mama bear is in that line
getting pizza me talking about the roast
beef sandwich got me craving it so i'm
actually gonna get that and they have
this
um italian soda that i've only seen in
italy before but they actually sell it
here and it's delicious it's like a
imagine like a fresh or like a more
authentic sprite it's a citrusy it's a
citrus soda i'm gonna get that
oh so hungry
oh mama got her food already i was just
going to take like 20 minutes because i
think it's kind of happening i got a um
pasta
how many sandwiches you get
[Music]
i'm not gonna pick up the drinks until
um 20 minutes that's all dog sandwiches
and what sucks they ran out of that
drink i was telling you guys about so i
had to get the pellegrino uh citrus
replacement but i can't wait to try this
let's try it
[Music]
mmm that's the spinning cheese and it's
crispy
how's that
so bummed
on the sourdough type flour too
fresh off the press yeah i've been
craving a little bit of pasta
so it's the couch with it oh that looks
good
can never go wrong with that yep
from right here la pasta fresca
and earlier i walked by another
restaurant
that was farm and had all this cool
seafood let me show you it's really cool
look at this we get all kinds of seafood
over here
fish
all that stuff
[Music]
look at this
what is that so this is prime rib uh
sandwich
these are fried shiitake mushrooms
look at that oh it looks so crispy
you wanna do the honors take the first
bite i'll do the honors then gladly
oh look at that
black angus beef
very good
every time i have this meat sandwich i
am so amazed
because it almost looks like it'll be
dry like it's missing something because
all it is is just meat and bread
but i don't know if it's like like yeah
there's no dressing but it doesn't need
anything
and i'm always reminded of it when i eat
it
because i always feel like does any mayo
mustard or something but it doesn't huh
yeah it's so good i love it that's what
happens you have really good ingredients
you just have meat and a crispy bread
and i just saw that right now their
manifesto
of italy
they choose raw ingredients follow the
seasons love our neighbors we cook less
we use less salt and we describe what we
serve
and they have it everywhere from like a
fish place right there to all the
restaurants i love italy
you can't finish off
a proper
italian meal without getting some gelato
especially
since this little dude ate so good
he's earned some
look at that oh yeah
[Music]
oh what flavor is that monkey
are you sure it's not poo-poo
what's that what's that one
wow he's raspberry he's raspberry
i got pistachio
he got poop ice cream
i don't know you like poop that much
okay taika are you ready to go outside
okay so taika is afraid of the wind
because he thinks he's going to blow
away right now i'm going to prove to him
because i just showed him a bunch of
videos of places around the world where
it's really windy and nobody gets blown
away
let's go
yes
come on come on let me see your hand
i'm gonna be with you ready
[Music]
[Music]
this is serious stuff papa fine serious
look look
what's happening
i know i know we'll go back inside but i
want you to feel i want you to trust me
okay
thank you baby it's really windy i know
i know nothing's gonna happen
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
has never blown me away not even one
time okay
okay wait wait wait wait wait we're
gonna we're gonna we're gonna wait a
little bit we're gonna wait what are we
gonna do because we're gonna go back
outside a little bit
okay okay
this is so crazy because never in a
million years
would i have thought that parenting
included
trying to help your kid get over
being afraid of wind and we don't live
in a place with like monsoons or
typhoons or anything like that you know
or tornadoes
we live in a relatively flat and calm
state
and
taika could do front flips into a pool
who was swimming before he was two years
old he went skiing
yesterday
and when the wind blows he's scared
which is
which is crazy but we're gonna work with
them and he'll be fine
okay so so papa had a great idea as soon
as we came back in
um
we're gonna do a camp that was it called
not a campfire is it a campfire
a bonfire and we're going to get a bunch
of trash and we're going to burn it and
tyke is going to be outside because he
says you feel safe with the fire on
that one
oh okay okay
but you you feel safe to go outside
if we burn if we burn stuff
because i think burning stuff is fun
okay taika
we'll go do that so you can feel safe
yes you can burn that box
boys
will be boys
okay so we have a bunch of old mail and
trash
you ready
you ready to do it
no way i'm telling you you got to trust
me i wouldn't put you in dangerous
situations dude
you want to do it by yourself
that's oh you don't want to do it by
yourself
[Music]
of course not i'm not gonna let you do
it by yourself we're gonna do it
together
okay
okay okay okay are you ready
yes okay we have more
yeah look pablo's setting up the fire
brother
was his head and that boss is dangerous
what's dangerous
well look at that small yeah he's
starting a fire for you with the water
no with with fire baby
oh yeah you ready to go
you wanted to go with me of course we do
this together
i don't think anyone will poke your butt
there it is you ready yeah okay okay
let's go you're so brave dude i'm so
proud of you
are you proud of yourself
good job
you're okay good job dude good job dude
good job
good job just be careful okay don't get
too close to the fire on this side the
fire's on this side so you want to stand
this way there you go good job dude
i'll help you do you feel the wind okay
stay right here
monkey
there you go monkey do you feel the air
you see
yeah yeah yeah move back move back move
back there you go tell me to rip the
magazine so you can burn it monkey look
nobody's holding your hand
hey good job good job duty you did it
you can rip the magazine let me see rip
it
monkey do you feel the wind
no you did no you're good
okay stay right there stay right there
not too close
you're doing great dude
are you happy
monkey yeah good job dude okay move back
the fire is kind of nuts
there you go
[Music]
oh okay let papa get it the fire's kind
of kind of big right now
good job duty